dans ce quartier où se côtoient de
nombreuses industries mathieu et un tous
les deux mois pour placer ses à pain
ceux ci contiennent des anticoagulants
qui provoqueront la mort du rongeur
trois jours après la gestion ainsi la
colonie très rusé ne s'en méfiera pas
l'homme doit être aussi malin que le rat
et découvrir ses préférences dans cette
boîte plusieurs parfums différents
j'ai eu une fois une expérience avec un
supermarché où on n'arrivait pas à
attraper un rat qui saccageaient qui
saccageaient les veillon de biscuits et
après observation nous avons vu que sera
ne mangeait que des pépites aux dons
qu'il a fallu trouver quelque chose d
astuces pour pouvoir piéger ce dernier
avec du pépito pour que le rat puissent
manger le pépito et là nous avons réussi
à l'avoir
les rongeurs ne sont pas toujours si
difficile la moindre kahn est jeté à
terre le moindre papier alimentaire fait
leur bonheur dans cette zone de forte
activité humaine le passage des rongeurs
a été important depuis janvier les
apports ont disparu sachant qu'avec
carré je peux en tuer 10 et qu'il y en
ait 5
donc je vais évaluer à peu près une
centaine de rats qui ceux qui ont
emprunté ce chemin pour se nourrir
mathieu ainsi une vingtaine de points
relevés autour du bâtiment
aucun autre petit animal ne peut accéder
à ces zapa
le professionnel en place ainsi dans les
égouts ou autres lieux inaccessibles aux
oiseaux ou animaux domestiques
mathieu est très prudent face aux
risques de leptospirose récemment
minimisé par les autorités interrogé sur
la recrudescence des rats dans les
écoles mathieu n'écrit mini la
sécheresse ni les incendies mais bien le
manque de prévention dans une année si
au niveau des écoles on ne fait pas à
peu près 4 à 6 dératisation même durant
la période scolaire automatiquement les
rats ça s'accumule et automatiquement on
a ce souci de rats d'autant qu'il y a
des écoles qui demandent d'enlever les
boîtes durant la période scolaire
ce qui donne un
libre accès aux rongeurs prévention
persévérance et aussi changement de
comportement dans les quartiers sont
autant de solutions contre les rongeurs
car si les rats nous aime tant nous en
connaissons les raisons